[Music]
has anyone ever told you stand up
straight or scolded you for slouching at
a family dinner comments like that might
be annoying but they're not wrong
your posture the way you hold your body
when you're sitting or standing is the
foundation for every movement your body
makes and can determine how well your
body adapts to the stresses on it
these stresses can be things like
carrying weight or sitting in an awkward
position and the big one we all
experience all day every day gravity if
your posture isn't optimal your muscles
have to work harder to keep you upright
and balancing some muscles will become
tight and inflexible others will be
inhibited over time these dysfunctional
adaptations impair your body's ability
to deal with the forces on it poor
posture inflicts extra wear and tear on
your joints and ligaments increases the
likelihood of accidents and makes some
organs like your lungs less efficient
researchers have linked poor posture to
scoliosis tension headaches and back
pain though it isn't the exclusive cause
of any of them posture can even
influence your emotional state and your
sensitivity to pain so there are a lot
of reasons to aim for good posture but
it's getting harder these days sitting
in an awkward position for a long time
can promote poor posture and so can
using computers or mobile devices which
encourage you to look downward many
studies suggest that on average posture
is getting worse so what does good
posture look like when you look at the
spine from the front or the back all 33
vertebrae should appear stacked in a
straight line from the side the spine
should have three curves one at your
neck one at your shoulders and one at
the small of your back you aren't born
with this s-shaped spine baby's spines
just have one curve like a see the other
curves usually develop by 12 to 18
months as the muscles strengthen these
curves help us stay upright and absorb
some of the stress from activities like
walking and jumping
if they are aligned properly when you're
standing up you should be able to draw a
straight line from a point just in front
of your shoulders to behind your hip to
the front of your knee to a few inches
in front of your ankle this keeps your
center of gravity directly over your
base of support which allows you to move
efficiently with the least amount of
fatigue and muscle strain if you're
sitting your neck should be vertical not
tilted forward your shoulders should be
relaxed with your arms close to your
trunk your knees should be at a right
angle with your feet flat on the floor
but what if your posture isn't that
great try redesigning your environment
adjust your screen so it's at or
slightly below eye level make sure all
parts of your body like your elbows and
wrists are supported using organic
aids if you need to try sleeping on your
side with your neck supported and with a
pillow between your legs wear shoes with
low heels and good arch support and use
a headset for phone calls it's also not
enough to just have good posture keeping
your muscles and joints moving is
extremely important in fact being
stationary for long periods with good
posture can be worse than regular
movement with bad posture when you do
move move smartly keep anything you're
carrying close to your body backpacks
should be in contact with your back
carried symmetrically if you sit a lot
gab and move around on occasion and be
sure to exercise using your muscles will
keep them strong enough to support you
effectively on top of all the other
benefits to your joints bones brain and
heart and if you're really worried
check with a physical therapist because
yes you really should stand up straight
[Music]